hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play followed by yes okay loose
man this came busting out of a door like
he was ain't no thing but he did not
count on them giving me a weapon stop
whoo okay okay you can you can back off
it's locked
okay um hopefully not gonna get murdered
by movement oh man lose man you're so
strong he just ripped it off its hinges
we should just like if you don't know
what now well now that we are finally
here we need to find the sacrificial
chambers but I mentioned in my book
dealer food what kind of book are you
talking abou years ago there's no need
for you to know the details about all
you need to know about this book is that
it is the key to our success
don't worry William I've read the book
the information in it will be very
useful to us okay y'all crazy okay it's
bright bright wasted oil and slow motion
sequence oh let me out I'm gonna get
some more open get out of here
about humming tinderbox that just to be
kidding me
oh oh
screw it I'm not even gonna like that oh
what'd you write all their sticky goop
yeah I need to get rid of yet another
slime wall
fine fine I'm not relieving my chair now
for a second this time
I'm gonna meet my enemy's head on apply
directly to the forehead
fly my chair directly to your forehead
oh no this is almost exactly like the
prison levels in Asia
hello was this door open hmm yeah
squeeze squeeze push my way twist wish
wish he was threatening right he looked
a little I have been in this room for
five days now and I've lost all hope
that I might be able to save myself they
might still be out there most of us are
dead now but Joseph left the group
earlier so he could still be alive out
there
I had water to drink but I haven't eaten
anything in days and I'm afraid to go
outside look for food so you starve to
death because you were scared
is it the keys oh no give me I need to
stop wasting my I'll never stop wasting
my oil are you kidding me
Oh do it give it was illusion good thing
I had my chair with me okay Oh
oh yeah my chair
no no green blood either the Hulk's gone
by here I'm about to be pwned
I'm about to be blown no but I'm about
to be pulled
hide me what did you open by yourself no
son of a [ __ ] get it oh oh oh
oh you troll cabinet Oh son of a [ __ ]
cabinet
how could you do those things to me how
did this corner even work you right
there
all I did was go no come back move man
Oh
oh don't
okay can I go now how you still here you
okay there's the newsman I heard the
call
going around all the way oh no see oh
okay
what about this bag I don't know I'm
whispering Holly we're just friends
gonna hear me Willy okay log down the
num and the hammer or something oh I
lost my chair oh I'm also kind of trying
to control my voice so I don't scream as
if I do would be bad oh how do I get
through the air cuz if stream all I need
acid to get rid of the mmm I got to go
get at more hassle oh yeah screw it I'm
lighting some candles on the way that
one
and this one it's down there well that's
where the acid is okay oh good whoops
man are you still there I don't care I
don't care anymore I don't care anymore
yeah I'm really I'm like trying to
protect my voice because it's still a
little raw and I can't go as loud as I
want to so if I start screaming as loud
as I usually do then I'm just gonna lose
my voice again and it's gonna be right
back at the beginning so and I don't
want to take another break for a while
Oh get outta here get all like a boss oh
not even a little bit of a problem
wind not scared I'm scared
no all right there we go but I can't
find the tool here I got like no oil
left it's like a pixels worth of the oil
but that's okay it's kind of lit here
man they are being really sparse about
the distribution of oil and whatnot and
especially tinderbox late other again
other games just load you up with
tinderboxes this one does not
please one tinderbox at least I get open
get open oh there we go oh that's a
chipper I need a hammer then oh yeah no
no no oh don't don't mess with me don't
mess with oh oh it wasn't a monster it
was just messing with me oh okay I don't
need a hammer then jaramana are out
there music is pretty dramatic
Oh Oh God Guster
I would probably die if I stayed on the
ground because I'm barely conscious
because I fail epic fail can't see red
Oh No I'm so full ah there goes my oil
I can you see all bulbus your Oh barely
conscious again how the hell ever one
hint
really whatever let's try it
tits
okay okay okay it's one more just in
case decides to totally screw me over
that's a big Oh epically bad double
skill
oh okay well the back man that this this
darkness is way more persistent than the
one that followed you in amnesia okay oh
yeah the padlock on by the moose man
he's still there oh gods so red
shouldn't be it's not barely conscious
just yet I didn't close that door I know
it do moose man I want to get by you
moose man then what the hell what the
hell you got a patrol up here now oh you
can't see me you can't see me
it was coming this way what why this
backwards is not where I need to go is
opposite of where I need to be oh but I
got another chair back off back off
let's go how'd you go buddy huh did you
get scared
oh it's perfectly understandable I'm so
ugly like walked in a room everyone
who'd run away screaming no gain of self
pity
where do you go actually I don't even
care not today oh there's my hazard
chair Wang
come with me chair 2.0 I'm closing that
behind me not that it's gonna make a bit
of difference with the newsman because
he's just completely obliterate
something it's gonna be a chase scene
hmm dark thank you oh it's still dark
it's still dark I got no oil enough
tender bye
I've got no tinderbox left I shouldn't
have looked at by a waste oh boy I know
hello don't mess with me
I got a chair hmm
hmm hmm what is this do what the hell
Oh Oh God
everybody are you so huggy you're naked
do except for some metal stuff oh oil oh
my goodness
Oh fully refilled first I guess I should
thank that oil container but no I'm I
thanked myself by what if I ever win an
award it would be like the most selfish
award my speech is just gonna be all
rambling about how afraid of hello
booster door is stuck in its position I
guess that's better than not budging
makes more sense anyway oh yeah I'm the
best
won't there oh yeah nothing [ __ ] what's
up what's up okay
I guess that was it cool diagram on the
floor so that's all the time I got for
now so thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye